(upbeat music)
(audience applauds and cheers)
- [Kelly] I love this.
- [Kristen] Thanks.
- [Kelly] The plum number.
- I'm cold too, today.
- I'm freezing. I started without
it and then I put this on.
I was like, "I'm cold. I
don't care about continuity."
- How lame are we?
Like it went down 10 degrees in California
and we're all like (shivers).
- Oh my god!
That was like when it rained the other day
and everybody, it's like, it sprinkles,
I'm from Texas, so it's
like I'm used to rain.
- Right
- And like it sprinkles here
and everybody's like, "Oh my God!"
- Everyone forgets how to drive.
- Oh my God, yeah and I'm just like,
"It's just takin' a left."
It's all that's happening.
So what is happening in that video
and how do I be a part of it?
You look so relaxed.
- No, I was having an
out-of-body experience,
ironically while she was having very much
an inside my body experience.
(audience laughs)
It's a type of face ma--
You guys, you gotta try it.
It's a type of face massage
that I saw scrolling on
Instagram and I was like--
- I have TMJ.
So this would be me.
Yeah, it's for stress right?
- You're gonna love this.
Yeah. It's called, well she
goes all over your face.
It's called the buccal facial.
Buccal? Buccal?
I don't know how to pronounce it.
All I know, is that it starts
with a lot of face rubbing,
a little bit of neck rubbing
and then they put on gloves,
snap, snap, inside your mouth
and they're going like all,
like they're like here
(audience laughs)
and it's wild.
And I think maybe 'cause I talk so much.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Lot of tension.
Lot of nerve endings.
And I feel like maybe.
- Well, pot, kettle.
(audience laughs)
Yeah. It's right here.
I am talkative as well.
And also singing, like I sing all the time
and it's like, people don't realize
like how you clench sometimes.
- She specifically said,
"You know, if you ever sing,"
and I was like, "Actually,
sometimes I do."
And it's incredible.
- Yeah.
I am so excited about this.
- [Kristen] Yeah.
- I saw this video and I was
like, "What's happening?"
- Yeah, I think it's like--
- 'Cause I love any kind of massage
or any kind of--
- It's like a holistic,
I think it's like maybe
originated in Eastern Europe,
but it's awesome.
- As all good things do.
- [Kristen] They just
get right up in there.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Whoo!
You took your, I actually took my family
to Disneyland recently too.
My kiddos. How was your?
Did you have any meltdowns?
I didn't have one meltdown.
- No, me neither.
- Rare.
- Very rare.
- And it was--
(audience cheers and applauds)
It was raining the whole time,
but we were just like,
"We can think about the rain,
"or we can think about Disneyland."
And we chose the latter
and it was awesome.
It was also really special because,
the my "Frozen" cast got inducted into,
oh, that's my husband!
- Y'all are adorable.
(audience laughs)
- I like him.
- (laughs) I'm keeping him
- My "Frozen" cast and I got inducted
into like the Disney legend ceremony.
(audience cheering)
so we were-
- [Kelly] What does that entail?
- [Kristen] I don't know but,
all I--
- That's exciting.
- You get a pin.
- Okay.
- And apparently the
pin is a very big deal
and I don't know what it gets me yet.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
All I'm really wondering
is if it will get me into Club 33.
- I keep hearing about this.
Yeah. This random club.
Yes. That like--
- Random club?
- [Kelly] Wait, no, it's
random if you don't know.
- What?
- I don't know.
- That's true.
So it's like super exclusive.
You gotta pay like dues to
it, which I'm not gonna do.
(Kelly and crowd laughing)
But I'm gonna walk to the front and go.
- [Kelly] With my pin, with my legend pin.
- With my little pin.
Apparently it's like,
yeah you pay like yearly
and then it's like a super
fancy, beautiful restaurant
like in the middle of
Disney that you can go eat.
And I also think it's the only
place that serves alcohol.
- Oh.
(audience cheers)
- [Kristen] In Disney.
- Okay.
- See? Alcohol. (chuckles)
- I don't know if that's
my kind of vibe either.
I have kids that won't do,
they don't do so great in fancy.
- Yeah. Don't bring your kids to Club 33.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But like put them at
like Ariel's Grotto.
- [Kelly] I just mean like
if you're going there--
- [Kristen] And then you go to Club 33.
- (laughing) That's where we go.
- Yeah. Of course.
- That's where we have to go.
I'm like, "I don't think
I wanna bring my children
"in that environment for
other people's sake."
And Dax I heard become--
- You don't let your kids drink, do you?
- Nope.
- Oh okay.
- Oh that's not true.
So no, I just mean that's not true
in the sense when she was a baby,
she actually, I was in, I
was in Scotland, I think.
And she, it was Ireland or Scotland.
I can't remember where we
were. And she grabbed my wine
and she grabbed my wine as a baby!
(audience laughs)
As a baby! And we were both
sitting with me and my ex
and I was like, "Ah!"
And I was like, oh no no champagne.
I don't drink champagne,
that's why it was left on the
table 'cause I don't drink it.
And somebody bought it from me to be nice.
She grabbed the champagne and took a sip,
as a baby!
- Guzzled.
(audience laughs)
- Only a tiny bit,
don't take my children away.
(audience laughing)
It was a sip and I went, "What?!"
And I was like, yeah it was crazy.
- My kids have ordered non-alcoholic beers
at restaurants before.
(Kelly laughs)
- Like a buck.
- Which sounds insane if you don't know.
'Cause context is important.
We've learned that over
the last few years.
- Yeah.
- So like my husband and I,
when we walked the babies at night
in our neighborhood when my
daughter was really little
he is a recovering addict,
but he likes non-alcoholic beers.
So he'd pop one open,
he'd have her on his chest
and we'd walk and like look at the sunset.
So as a baby she was like pawing at it
and sometimes she would
like suck on the rim of it.
So I think it feels to her
like something special,
something daddy--
- And they shared it.
- Something family.
And we've been at restaurants--
- And there's no alcohol.
- There's no alcohol in it.
So we've been at restaurants
where she's said,
"Do you have anything,
"do you have any non-alcoholic beer?"
And I'm like, "Maybe,
maybe, maybe we don't."
We just keep that for home.
- It's so amazing when in your own family
you're like, "This is normal."
But then you go outside and you're like,
"So that maybe doesn't track as healthy."
- Right.
- But, it yeah.
- But then I'm also sort of like,
"You can judge me if you want.
"I'm not doing anything wrong."
Like, "That's your problem."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's true, yep.
Yep. That's on you.
(audience cheering)
Her new movie is called,
"The People We Hate at the Wedding".
It premieres November 18th on Prime Video.
So did you guys do like
a family thing this year
for Halloween?
My kids are too independent.
- I don't accept that.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
I'm sorry.
I don't accept that.
I sat my kids down,
like a year or two ago
and I said listen to me.
It's very important that
we have a themed Halloween,
a family costume.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Okay.
- It's important to me.
Like I basically said,
"I'm trying to be vulnerable here.
"It's very important to Mommy to do this."
- I want to feel included.
- Yes!
- I'm apart of a team.
- [Kristen] I don't wanna feel scattered.
I wanna feel like a team.
- Yeah.
- So you can do whatever
you want for school.
But at home,
would you consider being
selfless and doing this
'cause it's so important to Mommy?
- (laughing) The level of the shame
- I mean I know I wasn't trying to shame.
I was trying to be vulnerable and say,
"You have things that are
super important to you."
(audience awws)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kristen] So we did
the Sanderson Sisters.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] I love it!
- [Kristen] It was great.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- [Kristen] And Dax
doesn't love dressing up.
He didn't take as kindly
to that conversation,
but he did not mind wearing
a full black spandex suit.
And he does a hay ride every year,
for all of our neighbors and he like--
- [Kelly] This just
reminds me of my childhood.
That's all we did, yeah.
- Get in the truck,
like put the the hay in
the back of the truck
and he drags everybody around.
- Have the trailer drag
everybody around, yeah.
- Yeah. It's pretty fun.
- Yeah. That's so cool.
I love that you don't see
stuff like that here in L.A.
I've never heard of that in L.A.
- Well you do on Hillbilly Lane.
- Yeah. (laughs)
I like Hillbilly Lane.
That's my people.
So do your girls, do
they share their candy?
Because my kids also,
sometimes they share,
because they want what the other one has.
- They'll do trades.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
But usually it's like a
big hands off situation.
I mean like trying to install the, like
"If you fill up this Ziploc
of full of candy bars
"maybe we'll get a toy instead
just to limit the sugar."
But it just never works.
- Yeah.
- So I'm just like listen,
"Get sick if you're gonna get sick."
- Yeah.
- That's on you.
- Not me.
- And sometimes that's helpful,
because then they learn.
'Cause my daughter used
to do that with ice cream
and I'd go, "Girl you can't have,
"I don't think you're hearing me.
"You're lactose intolerant."
- Right.
- And like she's not hearing me.
And I'm like, "Both of your parents are,"
so like this is not a good endgame.
And finally I had to like
let her figure that out.
- I think you--
- And she will limit herself a bit now,
'cause she's like ugh.
- I think letting them
figure it out is the,
that's at least the route that I take.
- [Kelly] Because then
you make it a red button.
- Exactly.
- If you don't allow it, yeah.
- Then they just wanna push back
and I'm like, "Okay eat.
"Eat the amount of candy you
want and see how you feel."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Unless I'm always like,
"Check in with your body."
- [Kelly] Check in with- (laughing)
- That's what I yell from the other room.
How are we checking in with our bodies?
(everyone laughs)
They hate me.
- They hate me. (laughs)
I love you so much.
- I'm so annoying.
- This will be the greatest show to watch.
So let's talk about your movie.
I loved your movie.
I actually watched it last
night after a birthday party
for one of my friends
and we watched it and it,
I didn't know what to
expect because of the title.
- Yeah.
- And so it's called 'The
People We Hate at the Wedding'.
- Right.
- Which--
(audience cheers and applauds)
First of all,
already makes me wanna
watch it from the title.
- We all know those people.
- We or maybe you've been them sometimes,
like it's just--
- Yeah.
- Between, not me,
but like we know people and it,
I didn't know what to expect
but it's, I want you to
explain it to everybody.
But also I expected humor.
Like I expected humor from
it and just from the title.
- [Kristen] Yeah.
- But it's actually pretty deep as well.
With like a lot of like
actual messaging going on.
- Family dynamics are a fun area to play
within entertainment.
- Dysfunction.
- [Kristen] Yes, exactly.
Because like when I read the script
and I loved everyone involved
'cause I'm like the biggest Ben Platt fan.
- I love Ben, I love Allison Janney.
- Allison Janney is a queen.
Everybody's phenomenal.
I mean truly,
I have to like breathe so deep around him,
'cause I just think he's
so wonderful and perfect.
- [Kelly] You two feel like
real brother and sister.
- Thank you!
- No. It was crazy watching it.
And I was like, "This
feels like it's real."
Like its-
- But like it,
when I read the script I was like
wouldn't it be great
to be a part of a piece of entertainment
that families could watch in their home
and let us be the dysfunction for once?
Because like I'm telling you,
the first day of this movie
I was thrown from a floating hot tub
into the Thames River.
Which is, you know, it's not,
that's not filtered water.
(Kelly laughs)
In half of a bathing suit.
So it's like, it's very dramatic.
It's, I mean dramatic in the comedy sense,
like there's a ton of crazy comedy in it.
But the family dynamics
are really like important,
how they're mending fences
and learning to be together.
It's about a family
that has to go to a half
siblings wedding in Europe
and they just make a
mess of the whole thing.
It's pretty insane.
And it's also just
about like loving people
through their mistakes and
learning how to be a family,
when there's been a lot of dysfunction.
How do you reconcile?
Like how do you come
back to the table and go,
"I've made mistakes and then
we've all made mistakes.
"Can we move forward through this
"and sort of like start
a new as a family unit?"
- A new narrative.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I like that too.
(crowd cheers and applauds)
So you shot the movie in London, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You were saying.
So like did you do anything
fun while you were there
or just work?
- No, I got to do a lot of fun stuff.
Like it was a six week
shoot, it was really crammed
and I went for two weeks
then the kids came out
for two weeks and then
I shot for two weeks.
We ate our way across London.
- Yeah.
- It was great.
- They have Indian food.
- They have, Dishoom, the best.
- So good.
- And they have like,
there's this incredible Italian
place called Lina Store.
We just ate our way and
we took the kids like,
on the London Eye,
and there was really great parks there.
It was wonderful.
- My kids on the London Eye was hilarious
'cause they started out, they
were so excited at the edge
and then like slowly
they backed up. (laughs)
- Right, right, right.
- When it started going high.
- It's kind of intense.
- Yeah. They were like,
"Yeah, this is so great."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Now it's like.
I was like, "Why are you moon walking?"
Like, "What's happening?"
(Kristen laughs)
"What are you doing right now?"
I heard that you also
did something really fun
involving stripping.
- Oh my gosh!
So, yes.
(Kelly laughs)
- I need to know this story.
- I can't believe I didn't lead with that.
In London, I had a transformative
experience emotionally,
because Ben took me to see Magic Mike.
(audience cheers and applauds)
And he took, okay, so Karan
Soni is also in the movie,
so Ben Platt, Karan Soni, Allison Janney,
and I went to see Magic
Mike at this casino,
which like those things,
if you're pitching a night
to me are not normally my vibe.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, "Oh maybe. Sure."
I would get nervous.
- [Kelly] Yeah. You don't
commit so you can back out.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- It was passionate.
It was gorgeous.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
There was audience participation.
It had story.
I like came out,
it had empowerment.
I came out like feeling the
London air, as like a new woman.
(audience laughs)
I can't describe it, but it
is not just a strip show.
So, see Magic Mike if you can.
That's what I'd say.
(audience cheers)
- I love how passionate you are about it.
- It was so much fun.
- I've never seen it.
- It's not so much,
it's sexy but it's more like
passionate and beautiful
and really empowering for
both males and females
and everyone in between.
And it's just like raucous,
but it's also really safe.
(Kelly laughs)
- I just imagine like,
I imagine this coming out of a man,
coming out of a strip club
and being like, "You don't understand.
"There's so much story."
(audience laughs)
- There's so much story.
- It was beautiful.
And I felt so safe.
- It's not just about the wings.
Hooters are great.
(Kristen laughs)
Like, it's like,
it's like I just heard it
coming from a male perspective
trying to sell me on it.
And I'm like, "Okay."
- This is not that.
This is not that.
- [Kelly] No, no. Even
if that is you, do you.
- Right. That's fair.
- They're taking your money.
You're the idiot and it's like--